[Music]
thank you
the glazed donut look you've got but not
the glazed donut look you want I'm torn
because birthing is an intense process
that should be depicted so everyone
understands how much damage it does to a
woman's body on the other hand the pilot
already showed in typical Game of
Thrones brutality a deadly medieval
C-section so I guess this in here is
kids
writers felt that since all the walking
in the show had been painful to watch
they might as well double down and make
us watch actual painful walking it is a
privilege to be amongst the first to
congratulate you delaying a woman who is
clearly in severe pain to grandstand and
somehow make this pregnancy about you
[ __ ] Lord Caswell princess sir
Kristen is not only alive but was also
allowed to keep his job last episode he
smashed a guy's head and then fled the
scene and somehow that was all explained
to the satisfaction of the king even if
this is due to the ever-present
incompetence of viserys at least give us
a scene where the other members of the
kingsguard talk about how he's a Loose
Cannon and none of them wants to be his
partner looking at Olivia Cook is older
Allison is stunning the casting for this
time change is maybe the best I've ever
seen I mean look at Emma Darcy they're
incredible okay sent off and then back
to me being annoyed what happy news this
morning while the prevailing wisdom is
that viserys has been dead for at least
a couple of episodes now the show
continues to act like he's surviving and
not decomposing sturdy
you will make a fearsome night referring
to a newborn baby is sturdy also pigeon
holding this baby into the job of a
night maybe he'll grow up and want to go
into show business as a Bard there's
this really successful guy named yaskir
who wait which one am I saying again
it's the babe have a name yet
we having this Jeffrey lanor did not
birth or even help make this baby yet he
blurts out the first name that comes to
mind without consulting his wife this is
how kids end up with ridiculous names
like optimists or Daenerys or Aaron can
you even imagine going through life with
a name like Aaron what does the second a
even do it's an unusual name for
Valerian oh shut up your name's Allison
I think I called the midwife
calling your wife okay so I don't really
know what a midwife is but I presume
they deserve some respect do you keep
trying Selena
soon I'll let you make it what it looks
like you if you're going to Mori without
an envelope in dramatic music you could
at least say you are not the father it's
like Amateur hour in here
[Music]
once they're fully Bound to You they
will refuse to take instruction from any
other Expo splaining dragon's position
overcooking your Shevon I initially
wanted to give the scene a sin for doing
that thing they do when they make it so
I can't see [ __ ] but then when the
dragon lights the pit of flame and we
get that contrast I was like whoa that
is really freaking cool I have to remove
one here but then I remember the time
when they made that whole episode I
couldn't see [ __ ] and I decided I was
still mad about that and yes I know that
episode was in Game of Thrones but House
of the Dragon being the firstborn child
in rightful Heir must now shoulder the
responsibility
I'm sorry are you doing foreshadowing if
so it needs to be in the form of
something like a burnt teddy bear
floating in a swimming pool you can't
just outright say stuff that'll happen
in the future might be like me saying
I'm going to send more of Allison's
Behavior just the most unremarkable
you ever saw that's the quietest when it
comes to full shaming we say nay nature
is a thing of mysterious works but
serious tries to pull a nature how does
it work as if he's talking about
something truly mysterious like magnets
did you witness the act itself no
Allison because that'd be weird all the
characters in this show have either been
aged up or flat out recast and somehow
in that process the production team
managed to make sure Kristen look
younger she flaunts the privilege of her
inheritance without changing as much as
I love watching Allison and Kristen
commiserate about their Mutual hay for
renera no no wait I hate it the show
hasn't earned this all they did was show
the two of them talking a couple times
in the last episode and tried to play
that off as enough evidence to justify
how this partnership blossomed
off-screen the princess for nearera is
brazen and Relentless I know right it's
almost like she beat a man to death
during her wedding Feast oh wait that
was you sir Kristen you're five cents
for throwing stones in The Glass House
of the Dragon beating your meat in the
summer heat till you eat your skied in
the city street also it's funny that out
of all the things the writer skipped
with time jumps the one thing they
couldn't skip was aegon pleasuring
himself out a window riveting character
development whose idea was it I think
it's pretty obvious yeah caught him with
his hand on the trigger oh you're
talking
to me dragon that doesn't sound much
better but you know what I mean either
way this in here as always is parents
Edmond is your brother
I can't tell if I just enjoyed this show
or if I'm going Delirious because of all
the walkie-talkie stabby [ __ ] rinse
and repeat nonsense in every episode but
it still gets to sin for only being a
momentary respite
you are nearly a mangrove and how is it
that you can be so short-sighted well
considering you walked in on him working
his gurkin maybe you should consider
that he's quite clearly at the age where
his interests do not go with Beyond his
man grown
you are the challenge Allison is right
that the boy she just walked in on in
hand is a challenge but as far as The
Story Goes we've seen little to suggest
that he is the challenge and getting
through episode after episode of
characters refusing to see what is
obvious to the audience has become my
challenge every now and then it feels
like the show suddenly remembers these
characters have Dragons It's a lot of
fun to watch but it's also gratuitous
kind of like all the plane thrusting
going on in the opening sequence of Tom
Cruise Maverick we are without
responsibility the political scheming
the endless shifting of loyalties and
successions none of ours over the past
10 years it seems Damon may have
acquired a semblance of care for family
and future which makes it a shame that
this episode only skims the surface of
this potential character development and
for all I know in the next episode will
be eight years later and Dame will be a
priesthood as traveling Scrabble
tournaments and the show will be like it
happened [ __ ] you deal with it at my end
I want to die a dragon writer's death
what exactly is a dragon Rider's death
I'm assuming it has something to do with
being eaten falling from a great height
or being burned alive and before you
suggest I read the book let me be the
first to welcome you to TV sins where we
sin what's on screen without knowing
what's on the page stick around we're
getting a petting zoo soon soften your
knees
feet light
your feet like your hands heavy are
these instructions supposed to mean
something relevant to sword fighting or
anything outside the transmutation of
matter also why is Sir Kristen allowed
to work with kids or anywhere within 100
yards of a school again I'm only asking
because he bludgeoned a man to death
also also he may be The Swordsman this
series deserves but he is not the serial
Pharrell we need right now let's see if
you can touch me you can add that right
to the list of things a teacher should
never say to a student the show asked us
to believe that Lord strong ignores the
clear issue of Sir Harwin being around
Rainier's children even though this
error and judgment goes against his
character previously being presented as
smart and calculating I don't mind drama
but I do mind unnecessary dumb drama
mixing in with the already existing vast
quantities of regular drama on the
attack encouraging child abuse because
you're still mad about your
ex-girlfriend's new side piece Let It Go
dude it's been some number of years I'd
have a more precise number for you but
the time skips have damaged my personal
chronometer calibration Beyond repair
most men would only have that kind of
devotion toward a cousin or a brother or
a son losing your temper and resorting
to violence because the plot needs it
and not because we know this to be true
for your character we send sir Kristen
for it and you bet we'll do the same for
sir strong you have laid US Open to
accusations of an uglier treachery and
wants treachery is that all right how
strong now is some skin in the game and
Sir Harwin seems like he could be a
formidable Ally to renera's cause hold
on am I starting to care about a
character I think I might be starting to
care about a character oh boy I can't
wait to see where this goes milk
swells the breast openly discussing your
wife's bosom and lactation with another
man to show the audience that you are
drunken [ __ ] and not because we have
any proof that Carl doesn't know how
boobs work
is a foot again in the step Stones
Genera Lenor shouldn't be excited about
going back to the stepsons but I
understand exactly why he wants to go I
don't want to be here anymore either
it's almost like making a world that the
characters dislike as much as the
audience was a bad idea a giant they say
who dies his beard purple and wears
women's frocks I'm not sure what kind
but this feels phobic and you live in a
world with Dragons how is that the
weirdest thing you've heard today for 10
years you have indulged yourself at
court
the
drunk the rarest of wines the lustiest
boys writers thought it'd be fun to
outline a very colorful decade in
laner's life but only show us all the
sad and depressing Parts you are
commanded to remain in King's Landing
and at my side boy you can do that does
that actually work I feel like Cersei
should have just done the same to Jaime
in season eight and now I'm thinking
about go throne's awful conclusion again
so here's this in for making me think of
season eight what does dead man never
die he wants you and father
and Baylor because you have dragons
there is more than one way to bind
yourself to a dragon I think the lesson
here should have been that you're still
valuable even if you don't have a dragon
but what do I know I'm not the blood of
old Valeria now I ride a bagel
the largest in the world bragging about
your huge Dragon to your daughter who
still doesn't have one wasting booze if
you don't like the alcohol don't drink
it but don't waste it there are
desperate skeletons to top grandfather
clocks who would love to have that booze
it is Lord blackwood's contention
therefore that the brackens move the
boundary stones and now is a gesture of
ill will the show will continue its
downward trajectory and give us what no
one was waiting for a riveting
discussion about a land dispute followed
by more indecision regarding what to do
about the stepstones of course the
entire conversation serves mostly as a
Battleground for renair and Allison to
try and best each other at politicking
but it's so dull I'm beginning to wish I
hadn't spent so much time complaining
about Sir Kristen killing that guy which
was still done by the way as you wish
husband but I am cold in my grave it is
very confusing as to how much power
Allison has by law and how much is just
due to viserys having no backbone
literally and metaphorically I think it
may have fallen out of his ass the point
is her influence seems to change and
become greater with each episode and
we're just supposed to accept it as a
matter of fact when it raises relevant
questions about how anything Works in
this world I have come to resign my
position as hand of the king I cannot
accept this you can't reject a
resignation viserys if someone quits
they quit if a boss could just decline a
resignation and send their worker back
out on the floor I'd still be working at
Chuck E cheese being spit on and kicked
by little children but I quit and look
at me now in a job of respect where I'm
left mostly without being kicked meat
without wine is also Laris releases some
prisoners here which is something I
didn't know he had the power to do and
cuts out their tongues so they can't
talk about the clandestine activities
he's about to put them up to which is
gross but fair I suppose however the
show gloss is over who the people doing
The Cutting are and how he plans to keep
them quiet is there a third set of
people who cut out their tongues if so
he'd surely have to keep them quiet too
where with the tongue cutting stop you
must push now my lady
mansplaining I've reached the limit of
my art really because the limit of your
art seems to be staring at the baby door
and yelling push I'm not saying Elena
wasn't capable of moving so quickly that
Damon couldn't catch up to her before
she got all the way outside and over to
vegar what I am saying is that Damon
might be phoning in this foot chase just
so the episode could end with the
multiple fire-related deaths of
characters the show has barely attempted
to make us care about you've always said
if you were absent from court she would
pour her honey in your father's ear
gross
bring him these two have been navigating
the ups and downs of their sham marriage
for 10 years and in the end we can still
see that on some level they care for
each other this relationship is just one
more example of great we missed in the
time jump all of laris's men wear a bug
on their bonnets because the best way to
get away was secretly murdering your
father and brothers by giving your
henchmen the same brooch that is
attached to your cane as we all know the
success of such Ventures really comes
down to branding
I love this show but it needs to sort
out these pacing issues and give the
characters room to breathe in one
episode you introduced us to the father
of veneer's children gave him enough
depth to be interesting and then
immediately killed him off HBO will
probably give you as many seasons as you
need slow down you may know what is the
right thing to be done but
love stays the hand show makes a valiant
attempt to amp up the drama with this
creepy monologue talking about not being
able to do what is necessary because of
the love you have for your children the
problem with this logic is that all of
the characters in this show are terrible
parents love is a downfall I know they
filmed a scene with Damon hugging his
children a screenshot was shared on
social media before the episode aired so
why did you cut it it would have been a
great character moment to reveal the
shred of humanity we didn't believe
Damon had in him how is there time for
aegon's wanking but not Damon hugging
his daughters you've had the stories of
Aaron holy Grace
built in Hebrews by Aaron the blacks a
monument whose own greatness not content
with all his monologuing Larry then
decides to open the Robes of History
nakedly spouting knowledge like some
sort of expositionist
you're beginning to irritate me we chose
an egg for the baby you didn't you got
the egg the Savages they eat every third
baby because they think it makes fruit
grow bigger plot
I know of no reason why the guy about a
treason ever be forgot
the tenants would pay their tributes
annually to their new Targaryen Lord you
undercook fish Believe It or Not jail
you overcook chicken also jail
wait I have an idea call a locksmith
[Music]
Fox
I did not wish for this this seems like
a good time for a drink and a cold
calculated speech with Sinister
overtones